what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation thank you so much for being here we're
gonna watch episode four and five of the i
am groot shorts episode one through three are
all in a separate video they're compiled
together there our reaction for that uh
really enjoyed the first three a lot this has
been really surprisingly enjoyable you know
there's a part of me i was wondering this could
be a waste of time they're so short but it's been
really really enjoyable yeah just the right
pitch yeah yeah so guys you can go ahead and
check that out uh if you only want to see these
two episode four and five then sweet stick around
leave a like i mean a lot also subscribe and
click that notification bell we got she-hulk
coming out next week so you know you want to
if you're a model fan you're gonna want to be
with us koi will be joining us also a full-length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code or your own copy meaning your disney
plus account over at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects thank you to the team at prepper for
helping us edit these down let's get that to it
little pac-man ghosts too
it's a ruckus
chris pratt in the shower
don't drop that bars
let's go
this is the guardians of
the galaxy easter egg video
what are you doing man
duct tape solves all
oh man wait are those the ships fuel rods ah
wait how'd you get the walls wet and on fire
is that drax's soap drax was in the shower ah dang
how did you get hey hey don't give me that look
don't think you're getting at us by being cute why
are you handing me this what is this more trash
better be a written apology you
see this oh oh oh this is very
nice the top of the fridge i
can't stay mad at you can i
get my tail here
i saved him i almost tore the ship apart i forgot
that they said bradley cooper was coming back yeah
for a second there i was like it's him right
no i didn't i could hear bradley cooper's voice
yeah especially when he does
the more like calm delivery
no hopefully this photo returns in the holiday
special they all got a little santa hat
20-minute season finale here we go stick
the landing final episode better nail this
yeah you could be on castaway
oh
hierarchy
i am god i am
i am
oh jeez
groot's going on galactus and he
full offensive
a bug's life
i gotta poop more leaves i was gonna kill him
you should have massacred those tiny creatures
i thought i was going to drop
it on them too harsh yeah
and this is among vin diesel's finest performances
you know i i feel like there's a way you could
make an i am groot like movie like like a pixar
movie yeah you know like you did it with wall-e
yeah and where those two characters you eventually
get to some characters who say more like the way
how it's been here where like you occasionally
bump many characters who who like can actually
talk or you get more dialogue but for the most
part movie like wally was so much more just kind
of silent film and just the same repetitive words
all through visuals and body language
and expression and this was i was really
engaged in all five of these and i was like you
could make some type of story that is like a
solid 80 minutes and i definitely tuned in for
that because this i am gorgeous groot is such an
adorable character so so endearing and adorable
and watching them learning and getting these
just the mixtures of of exploring lifestyle and
i love the way they handle like the perspectives
here especially in the final episode of you
know like he's small with the big animals
and the hierarchy of the chain and taking taking
him out that other bird and then he's now the god
amongst them and the imposing figure i love the
way that it all looked and like yeah the visuals
are undoubtedly beautiful and then you get the
family theme with the one with rocket there's i
don't know i was i'm pleasantly surprised
by how much i enjoyed these it's not like
it doesn't feel important in terms of the
grander scheme of the mcu whatsoever but
if you put that to the side this was uh like more
than a lot of times if you say something just like
really cute and enjoyable kind of just sounds
like something you could like i'll skip it yeah
for kids whatever i'm not a kid even though
i make a lot of noise about my inner child
yeah i thought this was really really sweet and
endearing and and very touching so yeah i i quite
enjoyed it i would like this is the kind of thing
i would like show to people just that that watch
is cute yeah i mean it makes me really happy that
they took the time and resources to make something
like this because they don't have to this doesn't
seem like you know the biggest money driver you
know business decision but i do appreciate that
like this had so much care put into it because
i absolutely agree it's like you could make a
movie out of this in the way that you know there
is important dialogue in wally but a lot of like
the dialogue across these episodes that shows up
isn't the most important part to you understanding
how everything works it is still mostly visually
driven mostly driven on action and body language
and stuff like that and so i would i would be
really delighted and dazzled if they grew their
animation department further out you know we have
stuff like what if and we're having you know x-men
97 and spider-man uh you know freshman year like
all these different animated things but this feels
different and because it's groot because you're
sort of in the live-action feeling world like it
feels like it occupies kind of a special niche
and yeah like i would love to see more either in
this format or in a longer format because it's
interesting storytelling and you can kind of feel
just the difference just the kind of difference
in consideration and sensibility that goes
into yeah a largely dialogue-less story you
know something that is just all about tones and
actions and and thoughtfulness and quirkiness and
and whimsy um so yeah like i love expansions on
the mcu that are like this or any any universe
really that are like this where it's like
this isn't the tone and media i'm used to
seeing here but i'm very glad it is here yeah
or they can make a movie and just minging it up
grew and then he's got like a bunch of clone baby
groots they just take all the cutest things market
testing loves and they just jam packed the movie
they come up with the most like you wrote it in
a weekend story but no if they did like a wall-e
type thing where they really considered like if
if you know the people who wrote this i think it
was the same writer director for all these like
if they collabed with james gunn or something he
came up with like a full-on story and really this
person wrote uh blue valentine it shows yeah it
shows boy yeah if they if they were able to kind
of develop something longer form with that you
know wally feel to it i think they also wrote a
revolutionary road definitely a revolutionary road
eyes wide shut written by them yeah vanilla sky
uh so yeah if you can get some of those
themes in there too basically it's romantic
life like an erotic thriller yeah yeah or a
hard-hitting you know a poignant hardship look
at relationships yeah recruits people maybe do one
where like groot gets like a a life-ending disease
or something like that oh i like that maybe we
made the very finale just to really hit it home
yeah to really make it really get the feels
going because you know if you get people to
cry that's a sign it's a good film yeah yeah
do angels in in the multiverse or whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh like angels in the
city in it yeah you know in america
angels in america with groot yeah
and then do angels in the outfield
i think that would be a very one-sided
game you know he'd make his own bat
he would stretch his arms out all right
guys what do you think about these
i really enjoyed them not just saying that
like it was just really enjoyable great
it was it was really pleasant yeah it's nice
to see something like just animated that is
you got to pay attention to it yeah you got to
drink in the details you got to pay attention
to the action instead of just a bunch of noise
and dialogue like it's like you know it's like
animation stuff can feel so bombastic and
just so like kids are into tick tock [__]
they all start off kind of slow and then they
build over time and yeah like these feel this
is like the best ways there was something that
felt like the word that comes to mind is serene
there's something there's very there's
serenity vibe to it you know um so yeah
i enjoyed that i was really blissful
and and delightful uh i don't know
this could have been so just okay or so like uh
this is for kids i get it but it's not really for
me like this this was wonderful it's like this is
for everybody in in a great way and the animation
too you can't say it like the just the details
and the particles like they they really look
gorgeous and tangible again it really makes you
feel like you're watching these animated shorts
but in the live action universe i felt like
they really cared to put something put these
together i think that's always another thing
that really surprised me i'm so surprised by how
much character doesn't feel like it doesn't feel
like yeah just throw it in there get your money
you have the kids watch it then we'll merge them
up we'll merge up group some more uh which i'm
sure they're going to be doing 100 but a real lego
set for each short i am i'm i am surprised by how
much how much more much more thoughtful this was
yeah yeah yeah it's not like deep and hard-hitting
in the fields or something like that but it feels
in a different way yeah but yeah they have enough
interesting emotions and nuances that it does
catch you in some kind of feel and that's that's
a great little yeah it doesn't always have to be
grim yeah to catch you in the fields you know or
uh yeah try to go for something melancholic or
something yeah that was great all right guys so
leave your thoughts down below what'd you think
of the iron groot series uh do you want to see
more of these short films subscribe click that
bell leave a like let's send this with a patreon
kevin smart new to our patreon page
so you're getting a traditional shout
out yeah i'm doing the elvis point man
k stands for kick it cool cool with a k
e stands for even cooler with a k than
greg and john v stands for vicariously cool
i stands for in it cool comma kevin n stands
for no one cooler than the kev dude you are the
coolest and you're freaking smart you're smart
you don't get too many smart people out there
everyone's dumb but yes my smart how do
you like them apples yeah i like that the
town ben affleck dude departed all right
guys well thank you kevin for being here
hopefully you enjoy the patreon or you
just pledge share support don't care
about anything we have to offer over there
either one's okay with us see you buddy